I'm Kate and it's time for another game
spot news update today we're talking
Star Wars which has just got a lovely
new poster it's going to look absolutely
fabulous on everyone's walls Disney has
released a new theatrical poster for
Star Wars Episode seven the force
awakens aside from john-boy jaegers
permanently worried face we're not sure
what or who the trailer will feature but
let's have a look at the poster first on
the poster you can see Rey and Finn the
film's two main good guys the main bad
guy kylo Ren with the cool lightsaber
Oscar Isaacs Poe Dameron in the helmet
everyone's favorite football / droid
bb-8 Gwendoline Christie in the shiny
shiny stormtrooper armor playing
stormtrooper leader captain phasma and
all her stormtrooper underling
stretching off into the distance and of
course the old guard Leia Han c-3po r2d2
and chewy where's Luke you've also got
x-wings TIE fighters a couple of Star
Destroyers and the Millennium Falcon
which fans managed to keep going somehow
and of course there's the massive Death
Star looking thing on the right which is
apparently a Starkiller base built
inside an ice planet it does roughly the
same job as the Death Star so make sure
you've ensured your star systems but one
detail is still bugging fans who's this
guy please don't be another jar jar
binks please don't be another jar jar
binks the new force awakens trailer will
air during halftime of Monday night
football's New York Giants vs
philadelphia eagles matchup the game
starts at eight-thirty p.m. eastern on
ESPN which is 130 a.m. UK time which
means half time should be around ten
p.m. eastern or 3 a.m. UK time this news
comes just hours after boyega told fans
to get ready linking to an Instagram
video which appeared to hint at what the
trailer shows what do you make of the
poster will you be tuning in to watch
the trailer which you can find on
gamespot and play over and over again at
the eyes bleed and your face becomes all
dry and old and wizened like the
Emperor's let us know in the comments
below I'm cake you can follow me on
Twitter at how not to draw and thanks
for watching
you